christian thank you very much if you're
looking for something to do this weekend
how about a little community and culture
at the summerlin festival of arts rocky
has details
jenny welcome to las vegas now
thank you so much for having me
we are excited to learn more about the
summerlin festival of the arts so first
and foremost welcome back i know you
guys had to postpone because of kobe so
how does it feel to be back
oh it feels wonderful to be back after
our one year hiatus we're happy to come
back this year with our 25th annual
summerlin festival of arts and hopefully
it's back and better than ever oh it
will be so tell us about it what can
people expect
well of course we'll have art lots of
art for everyone to explore
we have approximately a hundred
different artists from a variety of
different mediums
so there's a little something for
everybody you'll see
painting photography ceramics sculpture
metal work woodwork even some jewelry so
i wouldn't say something forever when i
truly need something for everybody
and it is all fine art so the arts for
sale on the lawn at downtown summerlin
it's a lot of fun to wander
and throughout the event we also have
activities for kids and activities for
pretty much everybody and we have let's
see for the science minded because we
believe there's art and science as well
we have faith lutheran high school it's
going to be out with a robotics program
and we also have the unlv school of
engineering who's going to be doing
science activities with kids
so
a little bit of science a little bit of
art you can meet and greet with mascots
we'll have balloon artists face painters
live music so a lot to explore
and of course we'll have some really
cool
new activations this year
so college of southern nevada the
photography and graphics
graphic design department
we'll be hosting all day each day
different digital design workshops that
anyone can attend so if you're super
into
interested in learning how to use adobe
illustrator effectively it might be just
the thing for you we'll have that
listing at summerlin.com so you can see
what's coming up we also have up and
coming artists from bishop gorman who
will be doing live art throughout the
entire event
and the local district arts will be
there doing large format live
performance art on the lawn so
lots to see lots to do
um oh wow what am i missing you can even
come explore our car show which will be
there on saturday
there are cars too so come see the art
of the classic car which is presented by
the
um classic ford and mustang club of las
vegas so tell everybody again where and
when and how they can enjoy
okay well be sure to join us on october
9th and 10th on the lawn at downtown
summerlin it's going to be fun presented
by
our generous sponsor las vegas review
journal and we look forward to seeing
you there
and we want to thank sutherland festival
of arts for sponsoring this segment you
can join the fun october 9th through the
10th from 10 00 in the morning until
five in the evening it will be held at
the lawn at downtown summerlin if you
want more information just go to
summerlin.com